there is some hope in our politics
and actually it's not it's not just
purely partisan
it's not just purely republicans good
democrats bad democrats almost always
bad in our public life but republicans
not so great either
a lot of the time however there is an
exception here to this dichotomy
tulsi gabbard you know
the conservatives for a long time now
have said
very nice things about tulsi gabbard
they've sort of fallen in love with her
i think in part
as you can see from the online
commentary it's because she's very
good-looking
very beautiful woman and so some of that
affects but but a lot of
the reason conservatives have liked her
is because she's broken with her party
on certain issues and i have been
a little reticent i've been a little
reluctant
to totally get on board the tulsi train
i've liked a lot of things she said
but i've been fooled once i've been
fooled twice i have had my heart broken
by democratic politicians who i thought
were trying to change things a little
bit
so i've held out but i have to tell you
tulsi gabbard
is coming out and showing that she has
if not perfect moral clarity at least
extraordinary
political clarity the mob that stormed
the capital on january 6
to try to stop congress from carrying
out its constitutional responsibilities
were behaving like domestic enemies of
our country
but let's be clear the john brennans
adam schiff's
and the oligarchs in big tech who are
trying to undermine our constitutionally
protected rights
and turn our country into a police state
with kgb style surveillance
are also domestic enemies and much more
powerful and therefore
dangerous than the mob that stormed the
capital
be still my beating heart oh my gosh
because she she begins this clip
in a way that you you think okay here we
go there's another one yeah the capital
thing it was the worst thing that's ever
happened it's worse than pearl harbor
right that's how she begins to
but no she says yeah the capital thing
was very bad
i think we agree with that right i think
we all basically agree
but what the
liberal dominant regime what this blob
with this
wicked corrupt rotten establishment is
doing
is not only just as bad but because
they're
so much more powerful because it's so
much more
vast and it penetrates so much deeper
into society
it's much much more dangerous
than what we saw at the capitol
absolutely
100 correct she is seeing something
that i would say probably most elected
republicans aren't seeing
and then tulsi gives her evidence john
brennan said
so i know looking forward that the
members of the the biden team
who have been nominated or have been
appointed
are now moving in laser-like fashion to
try to uncover as much they can
about what looks very similar to
insurgency movements that we've seen
overseas
where they germinate in different parts
of the country and they gain strength
and it brings together an unholy
alliance frequently of religious
religious extremists authoritarians
fascists bigots
racists nativists even libertarians
now president biden i call upon you and
all members of congress from both
parties to denounce these efforts by the
likes of brennan and others to take away
our civil liberties
that are endowed to us by our creator
and guaranteed in our constitution
if you don't stand up to these people
now
then our country will be in great peril
that speech that clarity
that tulsi gabbard is exhibiting
has knocked away my reticence my
reluctance she's still not a
you know perfect politician but
goodness gracious does she see something
goodness gracious that's leadership
and it's it's not even just this kind of
cheap thing where you know a
democrat becomes a republican and we all
point to her and say oh she's my
favorite democrat or something
she's not really becoming a republican
it's something a little bit different
than that
she's pointing out the blob she's
pointing out that corrupt establishment
i love
actually in that clip she plays from
john brennan the
to talk about the swampiest of the swamp
creatures deep stadius of the deep state
creatures
john i believe he also voted for a
communist for president once seriously
like an actual communist candidate for
president
john brennan uh comes out
and he says look we're seeing in the
united states
a kind of dissident movement that we've
seen in the dis
dissident movements in other countries
that try to destabilize the regime
now pause for a second
when john brennan and his fellow
travelers see dissident movements in
other places
they usually say they're really great
usually they love them they kind of
encourage these dissident movements but
they certainly don't encourage dissident
movements
in the united states and did you hear
what what he refers to as the dissonant
movement so he
the classic he castigates americans as
racists and bigots and
the nativist well hold on that's a
little different nativist
really there you're just saying maybe we
should reduce immigration
now we let like two million people in a
year we have the most
broad open borders immigration regime in
the history of the world
maybe we should bring that down sixty
percent of americans according to at
least one harvard-harris poll
think that we should do that that we
should the majority of americans believe
we should we should bring
immigration including legal immigration
down substantially it's hold a nativist
well what
so you just don't want open borders okay
and then
libertarians libertarians now look i
mean
i'm happy to knock the libertarians just
as much as anybody but
that is your example of a hateful awful
terrible group libertarians
by the way this just underscores my
point that i often make to libertarians
which is you're never going to get the
left to like you they hate you and they
think you're a neo-nazi so
stop trying to suck up to the left but
that's what they mean these guys who who
sort of
run the blob there are figures in the
dominant liberal regime
they they might love dissident movements
abroad they don't like the dissident
movements here at home
anything that that challenges their
established power
which is why they are undertaking this
radical program with joe biden as their
vessel good old moderate scranton joe
as the vessel of this extraordinarily
radical program
to undermine the very foundations of the
country
undermine our framing of american
history how we understand ourselves
and it's no coincidence that biden is
undertaking this radical sexual policy
in his first days in office all the
transgender bills to undermine even
human nature itself
to push forward this progressive agenda
that seeks to revolutionize not just our
country but human nature itself
that is a very scary project we should
welcome any support we can from any
corners we can
even tulsi gabriel even a democrat to
to undermine that effort to stand a
thwart that history that
historicism that that theory of progress
and yell
stop i hope you enjoyed that clip from
the michael knowles show
to check out the full episode hit the
link in the description or
download the michael knowles show
wherever you listen to podcasts
you